[Music]
if you love DC superheroes as much as we
do you're probably up to date with the
CW show the flash
well you might know everything there is
to know about Barry Allen but what about
his frontman Grant Gustin stay tuned as
we unravel gustin's secret life before
your very eyes watch until the end to
find out which surprising tattoo Gustin
has on his arm new around here don't
forget to give us a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more awesome
content now let's jump right into 20
things you didn't know about Grant
Gustin from the flash he dropped out of
school to join a Broadway production
some people are lucky enough to have a
dream and the will to chase it from a
very young age actor Grant Gustin always
knew that he was meant for the stage
with this in mind
he went after every acting singing and
dancing role he could find after
completing his senior year at Granby
high school Gustin got accepted into the
BFA music theatre program at Elon
University although he enjoyed going to
school as much as the next person
the Austin got an opportunity he just
couldn't refuse when he landed the role
of baby John in the Broadway revival
tour of West Side Story
he jumped for joy and dropped out of
school his second TV role was on 90210
for most of his life Grant Gustin
dreamed of one day becoming a huge star
thanks to his will and dedication he
eventually found himself getting noticed
at auditions and receiving callbacks
gustin's first TV role was on the show
Glee however he quickly shifted his
focus to 90210 after landing the role of
Campbell Pryce Gustin knew that bigger
and better things were heading his way
and he was right Gustin fit in perfectly
with the cast of this show as he does
have a dramatic Beverly Hills look to
him he was only supposed to be in three
arrow episodes auditioning for a
superhero role is no joke which is why
actors go the extra mile when trying to
woo directors and casting agents Grant
Gustin knew that he only had one shot to
impress the arrow directors so he did
originally gustin's character was only
supposed to appear in three episodes of
arrow but things didn't exactly go as
planned what was supposed to be a
backdoor pilot plan ended up becoming a
standalone pilot so in other words Barry
Allen was getting
very own TV show the flash the flash
broke records the CW had no way of
knowing if their new series the flash
would make a big after deciding to film
a total of 13 episodes the CW premiered
the pilot and watched as the world lost
their marbles in just a few days the
pilot episode had reached four point
eight million views which broke many
records at the CW after a few weeks the
network decided to go all-in on the
flash filmed a total of 23 episodes for
its first season this was news to Grant
Gustin as he had previously been told
that a total of three episodes were
expected of him the man can tap-dance
Grant Gustin is a man of many talents
and he isn't afraid to show them off
from a young age Gustin knew that his
feet had the need for speed what he
didn't know was that they would
eventually help turn him into the
fastest man in the world
Dustin's love for tap dancing helped him
become a star after all he did showcase
his talents on the Glee stage more often
than not Gustin explained during an
interview that he would forever be
grateful for his tap dancing days grant
isn't his real name it is not uncommon
for actors and celebrities to change
their names in the end they do this to
protect their privacy or simply give
themself a better stage name grant is a
great name and when paired up with the
last name gust in it sounds like a
superhero name too despite all of this
the truth is that gustin's real name
isn't grant nope that's his middle name
his real name is Thomas Grant Gustin
which does have a nice ring to it
he played a villain on Glee if you're a
Glee fan you might or might not have
realized that Grant Gustin is behind the
evil role of Sebastian Smythe if you
missed it it's probably because you had
a hard time recognizing Gustin while he
was in character he played the role of a
spoiled and conniving prep school kid
who would stop at nothing to win he said
he also ended up receiving some hate for
his gay character but it was all soon
replaced by the outpouring love from the
public he's best friends with Chris Wood
it's funny to think that two childhood
friends could both become famous on
their own time well it might be funny
but it's the truth Grant Gustin and
Chris Wood are actually childhood
friends however they have
small falling out while Gustin was
traveling with his Broadway production
so imagine their surprise when wood
landed the role of ma Nell on the new
hit TV series super girl for now it
looks like these two buds will be
rekindling their old flame this isn't
the first time that coincidence strikes
the actor though especially since his
old Glee co-star plays the role of
Supergirl herself he's getting married
we're sorry to be the bearer of bad news
but Grant Gustin is in love and he's
shouting it from the rooftops Gustin and
his longtime girlfriend la toma got
engaged in mid 2017 the love bugs still
haven't tied the knot but plan to
sometime in 2019
during an interview Gustin announced
that he and Toma were pretty much
already married however his fiancee
chimed in to clear things up she
explained how they'd underwent an
ancestral ceremony in Malaysia but still
hadn't signed any documents Toma who is
Malaysian by descent wanted to honor her
ancestors before sealing the deal he's
worth two million dollars have you ever
wondered how much the one and only Barry
Allen was worth well allow us to give
you the details it's funny to think that
celebrities have a net worth hanging
over their heads but that's just the way
we do things here on earth Grant Gustin
is said to have a net worth of two
million dollars which is pretty
impressive since he's only 28 years old
now that the young actor has his hands
in every cookie jar it's only a matter
of time before this number doubles in
other words there's nowhere for Gustin
to go but up he's got a man crush on
Joseph gordon-levitt Joseph
gordon-levitt is definitely one of the
best actors in Hollywood and if you
don't believe this just look at his IMDB
page this young and charming actor has
been pursuing his dream since he was a
little boy Grant Gustin made it clear
that gordon-levitt is the man to be he
stated that if he could have anyone's
career it would be his he even went as
far as saying that he wants to be him if
you're a fan of Gordon Levitt's work you
and Gustin have a lot in common if
you're surprised by this man crush wait
until you hear about gustin's troubling
past about 100,000 times the strength of
Earth's magnetic field
in other words yes he was picked on in
high school for being gay for you jump
to conclusions let us clear one thing up
Grant Gustin isn't gay as a matter of
fact he's engaged to a lovely woman who
loves very much regardless of this
Gustin knows how it feels to be gay
bashed every single day for a long
period of time it's no secret that Gus
Tina's head over heels for the
Performing Arts while there's nothing
wrong with that it did lead to him being
pinned as gay during his high school
years he told a reporter that being gay
bashed was a very hard time in his life
however it did allow him to sympathize
with his Glee character he dated his
Glee co-star for about a year before
meeting the love of his life Grant
Gustin spent a year dating the beautiful
Hannah Douglas the pair met while on the
set of Glee and immediately hit it off
since Gustin is very private when it
comes to his love life fans and
reporters had to find out on their own
that the pair had split after about a
year of dating they came to this
conclusion by stocking their social
media pages and noticing each other's
absence the Glee stars had too much
going on which is rumored to be the
reason for their split at the end of the
day two hectic schedules leave little
time for romance his character has
appeared in five different TV shows you
know you've hit the jackpot when your
on-screen character has a busier life
than you do when Grant Gustin was
granted the role of Barry Allen on the
flash he never once thought that he'd
rise above because of it within a few
years time Dustin's character was being
showcased on a number of productions
since DC comics tend to tie into each
other it's not too surprising to find
the Justice League jumping from show to
show in total Gustin has appeared in
five different TV shows under the name
of Barry Allen he's been on arrow
legends of tomorrow
vixen the flash and Supergirl he's
intimidated by Stephen amell's physique
whether we like to admit it or not we
all feel a little intimidated by others
this feeling tends to fade with time or
sooner if we learn the self love we all
deserve it seems like Grant Gustin has a
ways to go after all he's been seen
comparing himself to co-star Stephen
Amell Amell who plays the role of Oliver
Queen and arrow is known for having a
killer physique as a result of this
Gustin has joked around about not
wanting to be filmed next to him when
he's in a t-shirt
while this joke was made in good fun we
can't help but feel like Gustin isn't
giving his own body enough credit what
is going on with you two
babies nothing it's fine let's see it's
fine he's not a fan of the flash costume
it goes without saying that superhero
costumes aren't the most flattering but
when worn by good-looking and fit
individuals they don't look so bad it's
no secret that Grant Gustin is on the
thinner side but there's nothing wrong
with that Gustin admitted to not feeling
comfortable wearing the flash costume
during its first stages but this was due
to it being so tight he needed help
getting into it now that the suit has
been revamped many times over Gustin is
more than happy with it however the
young actor did receive some backlash
after a photo of him wearing it leaked
onto the Internet body shamers were
quick to insult his physique which the
actor has stated is simply unacceptable
Gustin says that body shaming is never
okay no matter who it's directed at he
once tweeted his real phone number by
mistake
the last thing a celebrity wants is to
have their personal phone number leaked
this makes sense because fans would
proceed to call them 24/7 well it looks
like grant gustin's nightmare came to
life by his own doing the actor
accidentally tweeted his own phone
number on a social media platform which
ended with him having to change his
phone number within a matter of minutes
in the span of ten minutes Gustin
received about 20 phone calls from eager
fans which shocked him to no end this
prompted him to deactivate his number
get a new one ASAP he's always dreamed
of Broadway when you have a dream it's
super important for you to run after it
after all many of us only have one shot
to make our dreams a reality
ever since Grant Gustin was a kid he's
dreamed about becoming a big-time
Broadway performer luckily for him his
goals were reached pretty early on in
his career after performing on Broadway
for about two years busting landed a
role on Glee and quit his production
while he never really wanted to branch
off into TV in movies he's happy that he
got the opportunity to do so in the end
the actor says that Broadway will always
be his first love and that he hopes to
return to it someday
for the time being though he likes how
things are going if you change your mind
I've been told my strawberry daiquiris
are simple
I will not judge him he is a huge
superhero fan it goes without saying
that most young children grow up
watching superhero movies and
fantasizing about becoming one
themselves sadly it takes a lot more
than wanting to become a hero to
actually become one Grant Gustin might
not have any powers in real life but his
on-screen personality sure does to him
being able to influence the younger
generations and be a part of the Justice
League is simply too good to be true to
say that Gustin is a superhero fan would
be an understatement
however his favorite hero isn't the one
he plays he has a Superman tattoo Grant
Gustin might be the man behind the flash
but he secretly wishes that he could
play someone else by now it's no secret
that gustin's favorite superhero is
superman Gustin told interviewers that
he loved superman so much as a kid that
he would spend hours drawing him he also
revealed that his Superman tattoo is
written in his mother's writing which
makes it all the more personal so we now
know who gustin's favorite superhero is
but what's yours let us know in the
comments and there you have it
everything you need to know about the
Flash's Grant Gustin thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]